ça
casimir bref pour y tu être dans deux
minutes près de la cage à poules bon
d'accord mais pourquoi tu le verras plus
tard aller
à émile et mieux pouvez vous être dans
une minute et demi près de la cage à
poules c'est super important monsieur du
snob vous m'avez l'air particulièrement
bizarre aujourd'hui enfin j'y serais tu
me consume
ma très chère amie mon nom moins cher
françois pouvez vous être dans une
minute pour la cage à poules c'est super
important quand on me suis dit compter
sur nous pourquoi j'en sais pas parce
que votre toit je les noms d'enfants à
losier vitesse avec
françois joly avez vous vu monsieur du
snob oui oui nous venons de quitter nous
a donné rendez-vous ici or il nous donne
rendez-vous et se paye le luxe d'être en
retard
[Musique]
ne vous impatientez pas ses amis
j'arrive toujours en retard qu'un jeune
aurore d'attendre amanda alors que se
passe-t-il
je compte parmi mes relations des
personnalités comme on le sait vous le
répéter 15 fois par jour c'est que
certaines personnes ont l'esprit lent
rebond et arak et faites vous allusion
est tous les deux capables je vous en
prie un bond de monsieur 9e n'est offert
bon j'ai invité pour quelques jours des
ducs des comptes s&d archiduchesse
dansante elle sèche
vous avez l'intention des bérets tout ce
joli monde
avez-vous pour moi une réelle et franche
amitié évidemment vous en doutez vous je
vous aime bien moi même et pourtant bon
pour eux si je vous demandais un petit
service
des
confessions ou bon alors pouvez vous me
prêtez vos maisons pour mes invités oui
moi je veux bien d'accord oui
merci beaucoup mes chers amis mais pour
vous dire la vérité j'avais déjà
télégraphie à mes invités pour leur
indiquer vos maisons afin qu'ils
puissent y aller directement à l'arrivée
de leur bateau
vous manquez pas de toupet ai dit
monsieur du snob si nous avions refusé
c'est un risque à prendre et je les
paris et oui les enfants monsieur du
snob à prêter nos maisons à ses invités
à partir de ce soir ne savons pas où
nous allons dormir je sais bien ennuyeux
de pas avoir de maison toutes les notes
sont jolies elles sont construites comme
celle de casimir avec des planches c'est
que dans chaque région dans chaque pays
il existait des styles architecture
différents très souvent les maisons sont
construites avec des matériaux qui se
trouvent dans la région où ils seront
bâtis
on va voir si vous savez reconnaître
différents styles de maisons d'accord
regardez cette maison les enfants
qu'est ce que c'est exactement s'est
construit avec quels matériaux
avec du granit les murs très épais dire
tu la prends
ceci
c'est une maison on trouve dans le midi
de la france une maison provençale
et veiller sur le toit il ya des tuiles
c'est que les tuiles sont faites avec de
la terre cuite et ses tuiles rentrer les
unes dans les autres
ensuite
cette maison
non
voilà exactement c'est un chalet
savoyard
c'est très jolie maison devient telle
restée maison alsacienne les maisons
alsaciennes sont très très large un
pignon très très larges et sont
construites avec des colombages les
colombages ce sont des morceaux doigt
entre lesquels ont construit le mur
ça ça vient de plus loin
c'est d'une tante indienne exactement
est c'est fait comment
exactement qui sont cousus entre elles
et qui sont soutenues par des mâts
dont il ya un trou pour laisser échapper
la fumée car on fait du feu à
l'intérieur
et la dernière
tu as raison c'est un igloo s'est
construit avec quoi
tu as raison avec des blocs de glace
également du feu l'intérieur
ce jeu était très intéressant mais
malheureusement ça nous a pas donné un
toit pour ce soir et moi je me demande
toujours où nous allons dormir
alors nous sommes vraiment gentil de
prêter nos maisons à des gens que nous
ne connaissons même pas tu as raison
judith autant plus que nous allons
passer une nuit à la belle étoile et moi
j'ai besoin de beaucoup s'en va et c'est
vrai 9 ou 10 heures nous font pas peur
enfin vous êtes tous des mauviettes aux
nuits à la belle étoile tous ensemble
c'est agréable non
mais vous
des oreillers il ya des couvertures
c'est quand je serai ravi merci six mois
il me faut trois ans tient à faire de la
3g
une couverture aussi tiens voilà
vous avez un oreiller
d'accord pour lé emile je vous installe
vous voyez assez attendez attendez
il voit la borde pas pour la has à moi
je prends ce matelas ne m'a dit ça ira
très très
sexy
s'installe la soul
macy du snob
bonne nuit un bonne nuit
[Musique]
si mes mains ont quatre doigts ce n'est
pas ma faute à moi pendant six ans j
aimais excusez moi mais j'ai l'habitude
de chanter avant de m'endormir
je remontais
gens vous emmène dans notre île au pays
d'ici là tu nous empêche tout dormir je
ne peux pas faire autrement je chante
toujours avant de m'endormir faut rouler
vous que je fasse beaucoup je suis bon
ok c'est mieux comme des moutons tiens
ça c'est bien pour dormir
venu à tous et bonne nuit et acteurs
venus saisir les jurys et un mouton mais
deux mots quand un petit agneau des
quatre moutons ouais
ça coûte bonbon fougueux julien pouget
pas possible votre village il faut
mouiller dormir mais l'eau et vous que
jafar laissez moi chanter alors mettez
vos couvertures ce reportage si vous
voulez ça ne réglera pas
[Musique]
papa maman papa papa
je vous emmène dans notre héros pays du
bonheur tranquille
s'il vous me rencontrer ne soyez pas
[Musique]
au coach ajoute au moment où je
commençais à 22
19 et dire que ça va être comme ça
pendant encore plusieurs années
il faut absolument s'organiser plus
sérieusement oui
c'est bien s'il fait beau long dans
l'île aux enfants les nuits sont tout de
même phrase
chausson aux pommes du café du thé et du
chocolat pour lui remonter le moral
casimir
et à prendre mon petit déjeuner il dort
encore le gros paraissent aller casimir
1 quoi quoi qu'est ce que ça fait c'est
au petit déjeuner
du gloubiboulga
non casimir mais il ya des chaussons aux
pommes et à bonson fait au beurre moi
c'est parfait alors j'espère que cette
eau bord dont choix du manga et 5
douzaine
d'ouvriers le café
voilà
notre cher emi où est il passé je le
vois pas tiens j'ai moi non plus il a
tout de même pas disparu
non je n'ai pas disparu
comme suivait de bon matin pour trier
mon courrier aimé
qu dort debout quand même parce que du
snop voici votre
ben voyons
alors
drescher du snop c'est moi nous sommes
au regret de vous apprendre que nous ne
pouvons pas venir pour visiter des
passe-temps plus somptueux nous
retiennent
salutations vos relations mondaines
mais alors monsieur du score vous nous
avez fait dormir à la belle étoile pour
rien du tout
sans musique saint jean vous amis il
aurait tout de même pu nous prévenir
avant désormais c'est malappris ne font
plus partie de mes amis bon j'espère
bien par contre ceux que j'ai invités la
semaine prochaine
ah non
blague il vaut mieux pour vous mon cher
fulbert anne bligh
le lance
pas une blague du tout j'en ai
réellement invité d'autres je suis dans
de beaux draps oh